imagine you're on a road trip with your
family the years 1954 and you're black
segregation is law in the south and
basically practiced everywhere else in
America you're traveling down the famed
route 66 and you've just reached
Albuquerque New Mexico for the first
time
there's not another town for miles and
you want to pull over and sleep for the
night there are over a hundred motels to
choose from but less than eight we'll
take you in picking the wrong one could
lead to a humiliating encounter or worse
a violent one but there was actually a
way to know where you'd be welcome it
was in the green book
Americans fell in love with the idea of
the road trip in the mid 20th century a
growing middle class meant more people
had cars and jobs with paid vacation
time and a newly built interstate
highway system meant the country was
accessible to a big part of the
population for the first time the open
road indicated freedom and traveling by
car reflected Americans image of
themselves self-sufficient curious and
spontaneous it was a way for families to
spend time together and see the
expansive country they called home to
experience America's cultural and
natural diversity through the 1950s and
60s the highway became the most common
way for American families to travel
motels and roadside attractions sprang
up along the highway to accommodate
travelers needing a place to sleep or
eat at any point on their journey but
that freedom didn't extend to all
Americans black motorists were turned
away from the roadside hotels gas
stations and restaurants that had taken
over the American landscape some places
were so hostile that it was unsafe to
even get out of the car sundown towns
forcibly expelled African Americans at
night sometimes violently black families
had to take prepared food in case they
wouldn't find a restaurant that would
serve them extra gallons of gasoline in
case filling stations wouldn't sell to
them and even empty coffee tins in case
they couldn't access a bathroom they
carried blankets and pillows knowing
that finding a safe place to sleep could
mean camping by the roadside or driving
long hours into the night even though
they had money to pay for a hotel
sometimes that distance was fatal it was
the exact opposite of the spontaneous
American road trip but thanks to a
Harlem postal worker turned travel agent
knowing where to go wasn't a total shot
in the dark in 1936
Victor Hugo Greene collected information
on hotels restaurants beauty salons and
mechanic shops that would reliably serve
African Americans in New York City he
called his Travel Guide the Negro
motorist green book and began publishing
an updated version each year using his
network at the United States Postal
Service which was one of the largest
single employers of African Americans at
the time Green put together detailed
information on businesses and private
homes that would welcome black travelers
the green book eventually grew to cover
locations in all 50 states and sold ad
space to businesses all over the country
with the help of s oh now ExxonMobil as
a progressive corporate partner and
distributor of the guides around 15,000
copies of the green book started selling
each year
Victor greens 116 page booklet ballooned
to over a hundred pages and became a
stable item for black families who
wanted to participate in the joy of
cross-country travel and it turns out
that iconic image of the open road of
freedom and family values would become
an anchor in the civil rights movement
dr. Martin Luther King even mentions it
in his I have a dream speech we can
never be satisfied as long as our body
is heavy with the fatigue of travel
cannot gain lodging in the motels of the
highways and the hotel's of the city the
Civil Rights Act ended legal segregation
in 1964 and just two years later the
Green Book went out of print it had
become obsolete and as the road cut
through the broad Plains you felt the
tremendous space all around you a
country rolling out to the horizon you
rolling with it it was beautiful and you
sort of sensed the real meaning behind
the word freedom
[Music]